welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and with Dracula
now dropping on Netflix it's time to
break down everything that you need to
know about the limited series after the
show premiered on the BBC earlier in the
week it's had the Internet in an uproar
and throughout this video we'll be
discussing the overall plot the meaning
of its final few scenes and the Easter
eggs that you may have missed there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch Dracula yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Dracula okay so Dracula initially starts
out as a rough adaptation of the Bram
Stoker source material before it veers
off massively towards the end initially
we are introduced to Jonathan Harker in
1897 who recounts his time at Dracula's
castle the two sisters these two sisters
become key figures in the first entry
and it's revealed that one of them is
Jonathan's fiancee and that the other is
van Helsing the former has been brought
in because Jonathan has pretty much had
his memory and life force strain from
him though he is able to discuss his
time with Dracula in great detail van
Helsing on the other hand has completely
lost her faith however after hearing the
tale that Jonathan provides she slowly
begins to recapture it and we watch as
this transforms a belief system
throughout the show in the beginning
though we follow Jonathan as he arrives
at the castle where he is met by a very
frail and weak old Dracula however
throughout the first episode Dracula
Benjamin buttons his way back to the
prime of his life whilst Jonathan
deteriorates rapidly from the off the
show uses its own unique style
that updates the classic legend
massively in addition to this there is
of course the gender switch with van
Helsing as well as hints that Dracula
may be bisexual
now this sent some corners of the
internet into an uproar
however Steven Moffat who helped develop
the show stated that Dracula isn't
bisexual he's bi homicidal the writer
later went on to say he's killing them
not
dating them he's not actually having sex
with anyone he's drinking their blood
the way that I looked at it is that when
humans eat meat we don't really care
about the gender that we're consuming if
you stray you don't care whether your
steak is a male or a female and this is
murdered and Dracula who consumes
without prejudice Dracula is able to
take on the intellect of those he
consumes and he picks up Jonathan's
English skills while straining him he
can take a person's memories and
intimate details about their life and
thus he gains more knowledge the more
that he feasts later in the show he
refers to this as downloading this also
adds motive for why he wishes to travel
to England as he views the population is
sophisticated and thinks that this will
refine his tastes though he probably
hasn't met me angle what an idiot it's a
really unique take on one of our
civilizations oldest villains and in
this first episode of Dracula really
caught my attention
Jonathan discovers a message carved into
a window one night that says help me and
he begins searching for the lost soul
the castle itself is an inescapable
forest full of twists and turns and as
he delves deeper into it he discovers
more of what is going on beneath the
surface the place is littered with the
undead and as Dracula calls it his
Brides who he is trying to use to
reproduce this is a slight
differentiation from the original work
as in that gypsies took refuge in the
castle haka is eventually bitten by one
of his Brides and Dracula takes him to
the high point of his home breaking his
neck and seemingly killing him however
the character reanimates and with the
help of a cross he's able to escape the
castle this is how he made it to the
Covenant to tell his story and yet it
kind of fills in all of the gaps we
realize that he's been brainwashed by
Dracula and that the initial account he
provided to the nuns were just ramblings
of how he worshiped the count
Jonathan's fiancee me now reveals
herself and similar to the book we
discovered that she's travelled over
from England there's a little sherlock
easter egg dropped here when sister
Agatha reveals that she used a detective
acquaintance in London to help find Mina
for those who don't know the team behind
this also created the BBC version of the
show so yeah it's a nice little callback
it's also a moment where Jonathan reads
a letter from his
Yonsei Mina who jokingly says that in
his absence she might have an affair
with a barmaid from the Rose and Crown
during the Doctor Who Christmas special
the snowmen companion Clara Oswald
worked at a bar known as the Rose and
Crown and this is a clear title Moffat
who also wrote that episode before they
get a happy reunion though bats
attacking by Mina and after this leaves
Jonathan craving blood he decides to
commit suicide in order to save her
outside the convent and lurking black
dog prowls the premises and this is
revealed to be Dracula I loved watching
him rip his way out of the creature and
it's one of the most terrifying
transformations that have seen in a long
long time as Dracula is a vampire he
cannot enter the convent without being
invited in I get the teases him with her
blood and it's from consuming this that
Dracula is able to see her memory and he
discovers that her true identity is van
Helsing left with little options
Dracula goes to Jonathan who he learn is
not actually dead because the undead
cannot commit suicide in exchange for an
invitation in he promises to kill a
character which he does taking his skin
as a costume in the process now this is
a massive change up from the original
work as in that Jonathan ended up
surviving till the end when Mina arrived
at the convent she nursed him back to
health and the two ended up marrying as
well as having a family together
Dracula ravages the convent and finds
Mina and Van Helsing using sacramental
bread as a barrier
this hammers home that mentally Dracula
is still bound by the legends that
surround him we learn that due to his
feeding on peasants who were god-fearing
at the time that he has developed a hate
of the cross and slowly his own mental
state as what's caused him to believe
that he has weaknesses that fit the
typical vampire archetypes we'll get
into this more at the end of the video
but a massively placed into the
recruiter ization of Dracula and wise
the way that he is using Jonathan's skin
Dracula tricks Mina into inviting him
into their circle we learned that van
Helsing sacrifices herself in order to
free Mina and Dracula catcher ser is an
awesome call back to the Christopher Lee
depiction with a look of the
character being almost identical and we
learned that meaner later went on to
create the Jonathan Hawker foundation
that ret diseases throughout the world
similar to the first episode the second
entry opens with van Helsing questioning
a character however this time it's
Dracula and he recounts his journey to
Whitby in England though it seems like
she may have outsmarted the character
last time it is revealed that he put her
into a deep trance that he's been using
her body almost as a milking cow and
slowly feeding upon her it's creepy as
hell and a definitely thing that out of
the three episodes this one is probably
the high point
Dracula begins making his way to England
aboard an ill-fated ship known as the
Demeter though this entry is a lot
simpler plot wise in the prior episode
it still packs a punch and it's where we
really get to know the titular character
as the boat makes its way to England
Dracula begins picking off the crew one
by one slowly making them all paranoid
that they'll be next and that there's no
one on board that they can trust I
actually got a lot of vibes of John
Carpenter's 1982 film the thing however
at this time it's from the perspective
of the monster we learned that Dracula
intentionally hand-picked all of the
travelers and he begins hunting them he
improves his German creates a fog around
the boat and manipulates the people
onboard into turning on one another
however after they discover sister
Agatha and almost hanger she proves that
it is in fact Dracula behind it all
there's also a nice little Easter egg
here as Agatha is located inside room
number nine Mark Gatiss one of the
Dracula TV show creators worked with
Steve Pemberton and reshare Smith on the
hilarious show the League of Gentlemen
Pemberton and cher Smith themselves
created a show called inside number nine
and it is possible that this is a
reference to his partners work together
they form one last attempt to take
Dracula down and he's seemingly defeated
but we later learn that he remained on
the ship hiding out on a bed that
possessed soil from his native land and
a last-ditch attempt to stop him
Agatha decides to destroy the ship and
with the help of the captain they manage
to sink it just off the coast of England
Dracula's coffin sinks at the bottom of
the ocean and we learn that he remained
in a coma
restorative state that allowed him to
lay at the bottom of the ocean for a
century he was discovered by members of
the Jonathan Harker Foundation and they
accidentally fed him which ended up
reviving him this is a big twist in the
series with the character in fact
arriving in modern day initially the
creative team deny that this would be
anything more than a period piece but a
dracula arrives on the shore to come
face to face with the woman who appears
to be sister Agatha now unfortunately
for me I do feel like from this point
onward the show did drop the ball quite
a lot time jumps can always destroy
period pieces and I do feel like this
was the case here with the creative team
being better equipped to write classical
dialogue than what they do with the
teenage characters they pretty much
spend way too much time on characters
that we don't really care about and
almost cut two credits mid-sentence
which left the finale feeling a bit
hollow in my opinion this episode
centers around so he found Helsing we
learn is of the same bloodline of sister
Agatha and she's been attempting to
track dracula down so that she can study
him zoe has cancer and this could add
motive to why she wishes to study the
character and why she ends up taking a
drop of his blood dracula is enabled to
feast upon her as her blood is poisonous
due to the disease and we watch is it
slowly ravages her from the inside
throughout the episode this studying
could be that you wish to find out the
secret to his immortality though her
motives are never really developed fully
as we spend fifty minutes of the episode
in a nightclub this is where were
introduced to a doctor named Jack who is
a member of the Jonathan Harker
foundation jack has unrequited love for
a girl named Lucy Westenra those
familiar with the original work will
remember that Lucy was a character in
the book and that she was the best
friend of Mina Murray similar to the
source material of Lucy ends up becoming
the undead and the show mirrors her arc
with her eventual death being a big part
of it there's a nice little shining
Easter egg with the wallpaper in Jack's
room possessing the same pattern as the
carpet from the Overlook Hotel but
overall I felt like the modern setting
lacked a disturbing horror vibe that the
first two entries had except for except
for the graveyard kid god damn well
there what the hell was a after dracula
is caged in almost
laughter s prison a lawyer comes in
freeze him because it is against his
rights to be detained left with little
options
Zoey drinks Dracula's blood and this
reawakens this pair of Agatha who's been
traveling with him through his blood to
the new world dracula discovers Jack's
phone and begins seducing Lucy which is
when we get another time Jim of three
months through Dracula and Lucy's
conversations we discover that sometimes
when people die their consciousness
remains and they become the undead it's
also at this point that Dracula warns
Lucy not to be cremated when she dies as
this will be extremely painful it seems
like he's finally found the bride that
he's been searching for this entire time
and he drains her blood almost
completely a friend reaches out to jack
who in turn reaches out to Zoe who is
haunted by visions of Agatha Jack isn't
able to say well you see and she becomes
the undead conscious in a body but
completely paralysed
she is cremated and then reanimates
becoming horribly disfigured do you to
have vanity and twisted perception of
the world Lucy isn't able to see this
and still believes that she is beautiful
together Jack and Zoe confront Dracula
and Lucy arrives discovering how she
really looks upon taking a selfie which
ya gain at one small kind of comments
and a vanity and how the camera never
lies she breaks down and Jack kills her
in some blade CGI death scene which left
me thinking where's Wesley Snipes when
you need him anyway after Dracula
confesses that he was besotted by Lucy
because of her fascination with death
Agatha takes over Zoe and the two begin
to talk because she's finally realized
what's going on with the character now
this is where the show probably takes
the biggest turn from the source
material and after she proves a Dracula
that sunlight cannot harm him she slowly
begins to deconstruct his psychology
Dracula is a coward that has been afraid
of death his entire life possibly
because all of his ancestors died in
combat on the battlefield because of
this he is subconsciously gained a low
opinion of himself and thus he lurks in
the shadows cannot confront God and
won't even look at himself in a mirror
it's a nice little subversion of the
character and we realized that the main
reason for the characters immortality is
because deep down he doesn't have the
courage to die what he's most afraid of
is the finality of life and because he
won't take this
final step he in fact has lost and is
doomed to live forever as a coward
zowie on the other hand is at death's
door accepting of a fate and ready to go
to the afterlife
leaving the character behind to wallow
in the shadows however Dracula has a
huge change of heart
and he steps into the light that also
has crosses on it and what are some of
the best iconography in the show Dracula
finally accepts that he must die and he
drinks so his blood killing himself in
the process the two dream that they are
drifting off into the siRNAs lowers
which is when the show cuts to black
this is important because Dracula was
obsessed over the Sun his entire life
and he longed to see it once more
finally drifting off into it at the end
and this shows that he has embraced the
thing deep down that he wanted the most
a death that would come at the hands of
it and the van helsings
Dracula believed that the Sun would kill
him and yet he still longed for it which
also shows a deep down he still longed
for death the to lock with one another
and fade off as credits begin to roll
but what did I think of the show overall
well I had high hopes for this and after
an outstanding couple of episodes I was
really hopeful that the finale would
nail the landing
however from about the time Jim onwards
this really lost it for me I do think
that they could have kept it in the past
and retained all of the plot elements
that were in place in this finale and
the time jump it just feels a bit cheap
looking back as a whole oh I did enjoy
the show and watching it on the BBC
night after night it's pretty much made
of most of my activities in 2020 so far
I did have a lot of fun with it but it's
difficult to not get the bad taste out
of my mouth from the ending excuse the
pun so it is quite hard to rate overall
I did enjoy Dracula more than I didn't
and that's why he gets a 7 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on Dracula and it's ending
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of The Witcher
Netflix timeline which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over the entire
show in chronological order from
beginning to end so it's definitely
worth check
if the show left he confused if you want
to come chat to me after the video that
makes you follow me on Twitter at
definition YT or head over to my discord
server which would be linked in the
description below we drop videos on that
early so if you want to see stuff before
anyone else and that's the best place to
be it's free adjoining we have an
awesome community so hopefully I see you
over there very soon we're also giving
away a free copy of Joker which is one
of our favourite movies of the last year
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on Dracula in the
comment section below the one it's gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
January and the cell be shipped out from
then to ever get surprised it's the best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace